greetings and welcome to yet another
analysis from this skilling open
in the champions chess tour today we
have an amazing game
at our hands and that is sergey karjakin
against magnus carlsen the world
champion himself
uh let's just jump right into it it was
a very very interesting game
let's take a look e4 five knight of
three and already
right off the bat we have a surprising
move
from the champion it plays d6 which is
known as the philidor but
uh it's kind of known as the bad
philidor the good affiliator
is to play d6 first and then knight f6
followed by
followed by e5 here which is better
than the bad philidor which magnus
played after e593d6
the way to exploit this uh exploit this
is d4
take six knight of six it's c3 and
i should mention very very briefly in
this position
e takes d4 is pretty much the only move
uh if you play something like knight d7
that can quickly be met by bishop c4 and
you already have tons of tricks to watch
out for
for example if you play bishop e7 you
can take on e5
and after after d takes e5 queen d5 is
winning another move here is after
knight f6
one can take on e5 and this is also
completely winning because after knight
takes e5
knight takes e5 d take e5 we have this
very nice move bishop takes f7
a nice trap there to keep in mind and i
can also mention that after d-take c5 we
have this move
knight g5 the difference in the previous
line
is that here if you were going to play
knight g5 here
black and played d5 so that is my
very short opening lesson for you guys
so e takes c4 kind of has to be played
knight takes d4 knight f6 knight c3
bishop b7
and here g3 and this is a move i really
like because this
makes things very easy for for right
it's very simple
i'm simply going to play bishop g2
castle
whenever black plays c6 and wants to
play b5 i will play a4
and even e5 in some cases and i'm just
going to castle
h3 g4 put my knight on g3 maybe start
pushing f4 eventually
and that's kind of what happens so
castles
bishop g2 rookie 8 castles
bishop f8 here we see yet another
advantage for the bishop on g2
perfectly protecting the pawn on e4
h3 this is the move i mentioned white
wants to push g4
or and also prevent bishop g4
knight bd7 and there we go
g4 is on the board a knight c5 attacking
the pawn but we simply
protect it with rookie one and this is a
very nice position for white it's very
very simple to play white
as i did say and it's uh unpleasant for
black
so magnus chose to play c6 he wants to
push either for
d5 in the future or potentially b5 in
order to expand on the
queen side g5 from carjacking
moving the knight to d7 that's the only
square
f4 taking even more space it's very very
very strong
strong move taking the e5 square away
from the knight and also
preparing some knight five here and also
bishop e3
queen d2 rook d1 is gonna come and put
applying more pressure
on d6 so a5
bishop b3 between c7
and a4 this is another move i mentioned
we now prevent black from playing b5
this would make things slightly harder
for for white
if black could play b5 and b4
uh chasing away the knight on c3 which
perfectly protects the pawn on e4
so a4 is a very good move very typical
in these positions as i did say earlier
as well
in knight a6 and queen d2
very simple very simple chess from
karjakin and very instructive as well so
you should pay attention to it
uh knight c5 rook d1 again taking the
open file
applying more pressure on d6 eventually
so white is already doing extremely well
uh perfectly played so far by
by sergey here bishop d7 from magnus
92 from sergey he now wants to maneuver
his knight to g3 and potentially play
f5 and bishop f4 putting pressure on d6
rook d8 knights g3
queen c8 attacking the pawn on um
on h3 i can't really see
any other moves here maybe d5 could work
it is certainly always a possibility
when the rook is
hitting the queen here but the question
is that if it works
if i can do something like this and this
does not look very good
but it's always an idea to look out for
i'm sure
magnus i didn't like it so that's why i
played c8
king h2 for from karjakin
very simple d5 there we go but now e5 is
uh is good
so like before black is trying to
put some pressure here on c2 and he's
trying desperately to get some activity
because his pieces are not too well
placed
queen f2 attacking the knight b6
bishop d4 now karjakin is preparing for
f5
east e6 potentially even g6 f6
just going to attack the king so magnus
he prevents that with
bishop f5 is also attacking the c2 that
pawn needs to be protected
g6 this pawn also stops any sort of
f5 nonsense
knight takes a 5 queen takes f5 h4
a logical move in order to give the h3
square to um
to the bishop but it's not the best move
and this is uh where magnus is good
he always spots whenever he gets it
gets a chance he always spots it and
this is what he does
again with the knight e6 and
the tactic is that if bishop takes b6
knight xf4 is very
very dangerous and this is just a
complete mess but here black has
tremendous compensation he's now
threatening the rook
and something like rook e4 needs to
happen and this is a complete
complete mess uh
but karika can he play rook f1 he did
not take on b6
c5 bishop e3 d4 and here
the only move that leads to
to a very complicated position like uh
probably every move leads to complicated
position but the only move that leads to
a better position for white
bishop h3 trapping the queen the
queen is officially trapped and
magnus decided to to take on c3 here
with the queen
perhaps knight takes f4 is better after
bishop takes f5 knight x e2
knight takes e2 gtx f5 the position is
very
complex rook takes f5 maybe knight xc2
i wouldn't like being bla white here uh
but all of a sudden you have tactics
like g6 takes an h5
and if this works it could be white
could be doing well
but it's always quite obnoxious when
black has a lot of pieces and you have
the queen and your king is weak and
everything the computer can say whatever
he wants but practically this is
certainly
not very simple let's take a look queen
take c2
rook takes c2 knight xc2 and here okay i
can play f5
which is not the best move but
it's uh it's still a very logical move
trying to open up a little bit
maybe a better move would have been to
play bishop g4 the point is that you
you prevent a plaque from playing e2
here you get some nice control on e2
while you can also push for h5 later
and also knight e4 is in the air
f5 it was on the board and here magnus
makes an error with
rook d2 a better move would have been to
play knight d4
where again e2 is an idea but also rook
takes e5 is now all of a sudden possible
and for example if i'm going to play
bishop g4 now
rook takes e5 would have would work
because if we take
we can now play bishop d6 that's another
downside with the f5
f5 move but magnus he missed this chance
unfortunately he played rook d2
unfortunately for him king h1
e g takes f5 bishop takes f5
e2 and here karjakin plays the very good
move
i take c2 simply take the pawn because
after rook takes c2 we have
bishop takes e6 rook takes e6 queen f3
attacking both and f7 and the rook on e2
so black needs to play rookie seven
queen takes e2 knight f4
queen c4 there's a lot of pressure right
now
knight c6 queen b5 knight takes c5 queen
takes b6
these pawns are now weak but magnus
always
finds a way to fight knight c4 queen b8
rook e4 attack and h4 rook get 4
protecting
take 6 knight takes b2 h5
and this position this end game
is very complicated it's certainly not
so simple to win
but let's see what karjakin did queen d4
knight takes a4 queen takes c4 now we
have a
we have a pin on the um the pawn of f7
this is quite important knight c5 and
now g6
so h6 h6 knight e6 karjakin is left with
only one pawn on the board and after
queen d5
magnus played the uh the error a4 and uh
lost after queen f5 knight eight
queen d7 and you cannot protect f7 and
denied simultaneously
and magnus resigned because the end game
with
queen against the minor piece is
completely lost the question
is that if he played bishop e7 queen f5
and then something like 95 is this
winning or is it
losing that is the question and i'm not
sure myself
uh i think i'll put my king on e8 here
as white but this setup here is usually
quite ideal
but you need to get it in the right
place
so it's certainly not simple and
a continuation contain g2 kg7
takes takes queen takes a5 and
should probably be winning for white
especially practically but
you never know
so that was that game a very very
instructive game
by karjakin he played extremely
extremely well in
the opening slash and middle game but of
course magnus he
as always he gets some chances and he
did have his chance
his chance would have been to play a
knight e34 in this position
with a complete mess
but of course the opening he chose is
rather rather risky
but he's doing well in the tournament
he's now he has the second place
behind anish giri and this was
an extremely important win for karjakin
who now has
um four and a half points i believe and
he is
trailing only um only one point behind
so if he finishes strong
tomorrow he will be doing
well and could
be set for the knock knock
for the knockout stages that was a hard
word to say
thanks for watching guys and stay tuned
for more action coming soon